des vignerons du val de loire sont en
plein milieu du salon entre les vins
italiens le champagne le beaujolais et
le bourgogne 200 vignerons un exposant
sur 10 ici et des rêves d'export cette
année avec le millésime du siècle denis
est venu présenter son saumur champigny
les importateurs
c'est minimum vingt ou trente mille
bouteilles d'un coup quoi donc cette
année ça tombe bien il ya une belle
année il ya une superbe qualité est
beaucoup de volume
donc c'est l'année pour se développer
moi je fais déjà un petit peu d'export
mais j'essaie de me développer encore un
peu plus de saumur à sancerre les
vignerons ont travaillé sur la qualité
les traitements disparaissent peu à peu
aujourd'hui le val de loire ses 282
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires à
l'export dont un tiers de vin bio la
qualité des salles on sait que c'est
très professionnel
c'est à dire beaucoup d'acheteurs vous
coûter des gens qui sont dans le milieu
et qui sont là vraiment on le travaille
pour
essayer de dénicher
des petits domaines qui
leur père et ça c'est vraiment important
les importateurs sont nombreux dans les
allées mais également les sommeliers
c'est un vin qui se vend pour ma part
dans mon établissement beaucoup au vert
sur les appellations iconique tels que
sancerre ou chinon les vins de loire se
font une place sur les cartes des vins
du monde comme dans la carte de france à
paris les vignerons du centre joue la
séduction
l'idée de ce grand salon international
est venue de la loire